the Joe Rogan experience do you that
thing that you're wearing around your
neck yes being as you are obviously
known as being Iron Man are you
concerned with wearing a large thing in
the exact same spot did you ever think
that life is funny because I was doing
this before I ever got fitted for the RT
so it was more of our imitating oddball
stuff I was doing anyway oh really yeah
oh well what Iron Man it's even more
interesting because maybe you were born
to be iron man because iron man
obviously had that from the comic books
loosely pre-arranged destiny and what's
incredible is how far afield you can go
from it and still find your way back
yeah well there's been no it's the whole
superhero genre thing is so interesting
to me because there's so many reboots
and there's so many like how many
[ __ ] spider-man's has it been how
many Hulk's have there been yeah there's
only one Iron Man though you got that
thus far what yours is your Iron Man
looks like this sir
certain dudes just owned a roll and if
anybody else tried to be Iron Man we
button well interestingly enough East
Coaster a dad of some renowned very
different my dad was a kind of a
underground filmmaker author maverick I
grew up definitely being Bob Downey's
seniors kid spent time on Long Island
which is I think where Tony was raised
yeah but when when Stanley was really
thinking that through he it was the
Vietnam era and he was thinking about
the military-industrial complex he was
thinking about how about if I can throw
a little bit of not politics in here but
karma and he gets shrapnel by the own
thing and it becomes you know so and
then of course there was the whole demon
in the bottle I think he was the first
superhero who ever like had that you
know almost like yeah hang up his jersey
because he's hammered yeah so I mean
yeah there was obviously but again once
something goes your way you can
draw all the parallels you want you can
call it destiny but it was it was
something that I definitely felt drawn
to and I definitely fought for and
looking back on and I go why was I
fighting because it turned out to be a
pretty special thing well it's an
amazing thing I mean you embodied it in
a very strange way I mean it's
inexorable at this point you you know
which is why I thought it was cool
you're gonna do dr. Doolittle because I
love the fact I'm like I'm a fan of your
work you've done a lot of great stuff
like watch and you you doing dr.
Doolittle is like a cool it's I want to
say you're not taking yourself seriously
but you're taking your trust that I'm
not but you're taking I mean this is a
fun kids movie about a guy who talks to
animals yeah you know I mean that's a
great break for because like if you're
Ironman like there's certain people that
for whatever reason become a role and
that is it that's what we will accept
you are that guy and you're not doing
that you're you're you're able to
through your talent and through your
ability to take chances you're able to
be a bunch of different things as well
as be the Iron Man yeah I mean don't we
I don't know if I'm noticing anything
now it's that it's that we need to shift
and we need new challenges and just like
MMA in society and politics things are
moving and morphing and the information
age is making things so everything's
learning and growing from everything so
quickly and improving or disproving or
or discounting whatever's happening next
but for me I heard that this was on the
table my missus who's my creative
partner in all things said Steve gig and
I was like I know Steve gig in Syriana
really what did he do he broke I like
that's a big turn for him yeah and then
I said but why why do I want and I
looked out and we live on a on a rescue
farm we have real Packers and goats and
Cooney Cooney pigs and you know it's
just crazy and I was like okay same way
I did with Ironman
I was like all right there's something
here and then before I signed on I was
just googling like weirdest Welsh doctor
I just want to think of I don't want to
just do another English accent so
there's this guy William Price who's a
nutty Welsh doctor he was a neo druid us
he was someone who believed like we
could communicate with all nature and
all that stuff so I sent a picture of
this wild looking guy wearing like a
suit of stars on it and like a staff in
his hand I sent that to gig and he goes
that looks right to me how's that great
let's do this movie that's that it's
always it you know any mean it's always
that thing of you click and you go
here's my here's here's my sense what do
you think and and then the other the gal
or the guy says yeah let's lean into
that and then you go but do this and
that anybody give me some of this and
you go yeah and all of a sudden you're
in a synergy it's like a good interview
like a good fight like a good dinner it
just kind of that the gentleman right
there that's a crazy look yeah to me I
just thought that's can do little B like
that he goes does he have to be that way
the whole way through I go no no when
they find him he's a recluse and then
the animals like clean him up and then
he looks less fun handsomer wouldn't
less weird for the kids for the rest of
the movie but let's find him like that
[Applause]